BOSTON UNIVERSRSFRONT
PAVELSKI COULDN'T GET THERE.
HERE COMES KANE TRYING TO LEAD
IN THE 1st PERIOD, APPPP THINGS
UP HERE ROD
LOVE FOR THE STARS.
DEBRINCAT PASSES
LEFT OF MARC-ANDREBETWEEN
KING AND BOWNESS.
THEIR STYLES, PLAYERS, COACHES.
THEYSETH JONES IS A BIG PART OF
PEOPLE HAD TO STAY ANDTCHES IN,G
SQUEEZED BY STROME AND JONES OF
THE HAWKS.
GOAL LINE, STROME ACROSS AND
HIT BY DEBRINCAT.
JONES LITTLE TOOHE
LOOK IN FRONT, CARPENTER
LAYS THAT BACK IN ON OETTINGER.
MOSTTHE VIDEO DO THE T BETTER PE
PUCK IN  AND
McCACAEAT PLAY BY KUBALIK TO FE
STROHM.
HEBAD SHIFT
THEY'VE HAD WITH ALL OF THE
PRESSURE.
WAY TO THE
KNEE PADS OF OETTINGER.
NO REBOUNDCENTER, THE
APPROACH ANY DIFFERENT FOR THE
FINAL 90?
>> Colby: NO, EVERYTHING HAS
TO BE N AND
REGULATION SINCE
DECEMBER 9,
THROUGH THE FIRST TWO PERIODS,
BUT YO
POKE CHECK BY PATRICK KANE.
BENN, SEGUIN AND FOR THE STARS.
4.5  SEGUIN
CHANCE THAT RUNG UP.
WE KNOW W
IT.
>> Chris: HETHE OUTLET PASS BY
CALEB JONES AND PATRICK KANE
OUT ON THE AND NOW SEGUIN FROM E
SHOOTS, SAVE OETTINGER.
SEGUIN WITH THE REBOUND.
BACK TO HIS S SECOND STRAIGHT
GAME3 ON
3.           GURIANOV,
KLINGBERG
GAME WINNER R OFF  OF THE CIRCL
GIVEG THE SPLIT,
PUSHING, PUSHING.
MARC-ANDRE FLEURY  AFTER THIS
THING BANGS OFF THE POST
>> Colby: MARC- TO GET
AROUND HIM.
ROUND FIVE, HERETO SHOOT THE PUS
TO BEAT HIM UP OVER THE SIDE THE
SAVES THESE DAYS.
ROOPE HINTZ UP IN  LOVE
FOR THE DEFENSE.
HERE COMES
THAT HIT OFF THE END OF THE